so we have this girl right over here and
she is 1.7 meters tall and she's
standing in the sun and the sun's at an
angle with respect to the ground
the sun is at an angle with respect to
the ground and given where the sun is
right now her shadow is 3.1 meters long
what i want you to do is pause this
video and try to figure out that angle
of the sun relative to the ground or
another way let me be a little more
specific
pause the video and try to figure out
what this angle is and figure it out in
terms of radians
so as you might imagine this we have an
angle and then we have the lengths of
two sides and we could figure out the
ratios of the lengths of sides so this
might be involving a little bit of
trigonometry and which of our trig
functions if we're talking about this
angle right over here which of our trig
functions deal with the opposite
and the adjacent
well we could remind ourselves with a
little bit of sohcahtoa
sine is opposite over hypotenuse
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse and
tangent is opposite over adjacent
opposite over adjacent
so tangent is what we would use it's
dealing with opposite and adjacent so we
could say that the tangent
of theta
is equal to 1.7 meters
1.7 meters over 3.1 meters
over 3.1 meters so we need to figure out
some angle theta in radians where if i
take the tangent of it i'm going to get
1.7 over 3.1 or another way we could
think about it we could take the inverse
tan function or tangent function of both
sides of this sometimes called the arc
cosine arc sometimes called the arc
tangent so if we take the inverse
tangent of both sides of this we are
going to be left with theta is equal to
the inverse tangent of 1.7
1.7
over 3.1
over
3.1 and this isn't something that's very
easy to kind of look at the unit circle
and try to figure out what this is going
to be so let's just use our calculator
for this one
so let's see we want to take
the inverse tangent
so
give me the angle whose tangent is the
number that i'm the argument that i'm
going to give to this inverse tangent
function the inverse tangent of 1.7
over
3.1 and before i even before i even
press enter here let me make sure i'm in
the right mode so no i'm not in the
right mode so i was in degree mode let
me go into radian mode we said that we
wanted the answer in radians so let's
exit from this and now we
are going to get our answer in radians
and so if we were to round to the
nearest hundredths this would give us
about pretty close to 0.50
so this is
approximately
equal to 0.5
if we round to the nearest hundredths
that's the measure of this angle in
radians i could write 0.50
radians